روسيا تعزيز دفاعاتها في منطقتي زبريجيا
وروجانيس في اوكرانيا تحسبا لهجوم ربما
ستشنه القوات الاوكرانيه قريبا وفقا
لتقرير الاستخبارات بريطانيا التقرير
البريطاني رجح ان تحقق القوات الاوكرانيه
تقدما كبيرا في ذا برجيا سيشكل تحديا
للجسر البري الروسي الذي يربط منطقه
روستوف الروسيه وشبه جزيره القرم اما في
مدينه بخمود فان المعارك تحتدمه هناك
بالاضافه الى وسط سوريدار بمقاطعه حيث
يتواصلوا القصف الروسي لدفع الجيش
الاوكراني على الانسحاب منها الى بق محمود
وترهن روسي على استراتيجيه ذات محورين
اولهما تكثيف قوه النيران ومن الصواريخ
البحريه بعد الدفع بقطع حديثه مثبت عليها
صواريخ سيركون خلال الايام الماضيه
والمحور الثاني تضييق الخناق على القوات
الاوكرانيه في محيط بخمه اهم المعارك
الحاليه لسيطره على كامل دونتستك في
المقابل يقول تقرير حديث لمركز دراسه
الحرب الامريكيه ان المكاسب الروسيه في
سوليدار لا تنظر بتطويق وشيك لخمه لان
الامر يتعلق بضروره السيطره على اثنين من
الطرق السريعه بطول 13 كيلو مترا بينما
تتقدم القوات الروسيه بصعوبه